we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p on the
voicemail on the bonus show yesterday we
were talking about should systems
welfare system social services
prioritize women and children over men
if so why if not why not
we heard from the egg man about the
issue take a listen he did as a society
i think we should care more about
homeless women and children than
homeless men they're more vulnerable
i've been a homeless man it was easy for
me to find a van for five hundred bucks
800 bucks and live in a van and i never
felt threatened i never felt unsafe in
some places that park may be a little
bit only by the cops really absolutely
all the only people who threatened me
but i'm so women and children it is much
more threatening and vulnerable to the
homeless person they deserve more they
should be put in shelters first men
shouldn't be left out but women and
children are more vulnerable in this
society back when you need to have kids
okay you need to make some vulnerable
members of society and learn how to take
care of them and make you a more
compassionate liberal human yeah
pat that was basically the consensus
that there is more vulnerability in
society for women and children and it's
not that they are worth more than men
but it is logical to ford them
additional protections or prioritized
protections for them in the homeless
community a surprised that that's the
consensus view of the audience
no not surprised the eggman does agree
with rudy giuliani on this though that
men are disposable and i think he should
expect some men's rights advocates to go
after him the MRA community will be
crushing the egg man before you know it
we've got a great bonus show for you
today i'm out of time to tell you what's
on it but it is a really good one i'll
speak to you then